Italy started reopening this week but
fears of the coronavirus remain
especially among older people the
country has the second oldest population
of any nation in the world volunteers in
Venice are finding a unique way to get
supplies to those who need it Chris
lives Sade traveled there to show us how
a group of female gondoliers are rowing
up to help throughout this pandemic
getting groceries has been difficult for
all of us especially the elderly well
here in the city of canals volunteers
have found a solution that couldn't be
more Venetian these aren't your typical
gondolas and these aren't your typical
gondoliers all women not one but two to
a boat and instead of serenading
tourists they're delivering organic food
to locals farmers from around the lagoon
load the orders aboard
Giulia tell you Pietro a competitive
rower says she and the others were stuck
at home unable to train for racing
season during the coronavirus lockdown
so now we do these like twice or three
times a week
and it also helps us because we can go
out and breathe and bro her city has
been drowning this past fall saw the
worst flooding in a generation as it was
struggling to recover
Kovac 19 struck killing a relative few
but decimating the main industry here
tourism while forcing the elderly to
shelter at home this in a city that's
shrunk from more than 170,000 people
after World War two to just over 50,000
today as mass tourism pushes living
costs up and locals out Venetians truly
are an endangered species and these food
deliveries are just one way of helping
save them from extinction
rain or shine gondoliers deliver at
drop-off points around the city so you
think this is really important Quinn
deal a paints legacy amount importante
Westec insane fantasy yes says this
customer it's inspiring to see it
delivered in a traditional venetian boat
food isn't the only thing they need in
this city with no cars volunteers also
deliver medicine by foot it saved your
life yes me with my broken arm she says
and my 90 year old mother she calls
volunteer Marco Capital auto angel in
the end it could be your grandparents it
could be your elderly aunt or family
member so you find lonely people that
maybe sometimes need also someone who's
friendly with them someone who's caring
somehow and it feels very nice
delivering food medicine and also
solidarity to a battered city with an
unsinkable way of life and the
volunteers want to continue delivering
food even after the lockdown they say
it's good for the body and good for the
soul Chris lips say CBS News Venice yes
Chris has such a Venetian way to solve
the problem my favorite city in the
world Gail everybody wonders about that
painting behind me it's a scene of
Venice there's a reason it's there yeah
I get why it's your favorite city in the
world there's no place like it not once
again it's another example Tony of
people stepping up going above and
beyond the call of duty it's happening
all over the world that's a great one I
love that was all women too I like that
part the story yeah very cool you know
they're up there on the canal and
they've got a boat they've got an oar
places to go things to deliver it's
working I like it a lot
it's a beautiful scene